after weeks of closed-door Democratic
impeachment meetings congressman Matt
Gaetz leads a group of Republicans to
storm the secretive deposition room to
demand transparency meanwhile a top aide
to Hillary Clinton signals that
America's favorite battle axe may be
running again some fear the u.s. is
headed towards civil war I fear a far
more dreadful future we are becoming
Great Britain we will analyze our
political polarization then Hillary 3.0
gets a big boost some good news from
Syria after bad news on the domestic
front finally the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
all right so yesterday a big fireworks
fly in the Congress because Republicans
stormed the impeachment proceedings they
ran down there it was chaos it was
madness okay so that wasn't I guess that
wasn't that exciting but if you asked
Democratic Rep Gerry Connolly it was
madness Gerry says the whole thing was
threatening shouting back and forth i
sat down and all of a sudden the room
filled up with non committee members
initially it was a little hard to
realize what was happening in fact to be
honest with you I got a little concerned
don't forget by the way when people
regularly use the phrase to be honest
with you it means that they're generally
not honest with you and I think that's
what's coming from the Democrats this
was not some crazy kicked down the doors
we're taking over this is a coup d'etat
it was Republicans asking to be led into
a room for the impeachment proceedings
that they should be invited to so not
not exactly threatening but this was a
total setup this was a complete bit of
political theater from the Republicans
but the whole impeachment proceedings
are political theater from the Democrats
when you think about impeachment I think
what people are trying to do is they're
trying to figure out what is this
impeachment about something with Ukraine
and Joe Biden and a phone call and
that's the wrong way to think about it
you have to look on the longer scale
Democrats have been in trying to impeach
president Trump since before he took
office who's the guy leading the
impeachment George it's Adams ship Adam
Schiff rather Adam Schiff has been
caught lying time and time again Adam
Schiff has been caught leaking time and
time again Adam Schiff has been caught
in the pockets of leakers from the
intelligence community time and time
again now he is leading this in
HMN inquiry based on anonymous
whistleblowers from from within the
bureaucracy that we will never hear from
okay and he's passing along this
information which is hearsay which is
secondhand from these anonymous
whistleblowers who we already found out
from the IG are biased first we found
out the whistleblower this brave
wonderful American from the intelligence
community had shown demonstrable bias of
opposing Donald Trump we then found out
he formerly worked on the staff of a
Democrat we just found out today there
is a third evidence of anti-trump bias
from this whistleblower that we don't
know the nature of that bias yet and
there's a real irony here too because
when Barack Obama Trump's predecessor
had a real scandal the Fast & Furious
scandal where he was running guns across
our border there was a whistleblower in
that case too and do you know what
Barack Obama did to that whistleblower
did he exalt him did he elevate him did
he bring him behind closed door meetings
to testify no he fired him guys name was
John Dodson everything about this case
though is secret the reason that
everything is secret in this case is
because they don't want those
consequences they don't want it to
become clear this is a total setup like
all the other setups for the past three
years they don't want the witness to be
cross-examined by the public or by
anybody else
they don't want President Trump to be
able to face his accuser you know in the
case of the Obama fast Ramirez
whistleblower we knew the guy's name we
know the guy's name today if Adam Schiff
and the House Democrats have their way
we're never going to find out so they've
been for weeks and weeks secretly
deposing all of these witnesses then
yesterday Laura Cooper who is a Pentagon
official she oversaw Ukraine policy she
was subpoenaed to testify and the
testimony was supposed to be classified
testimony that's why it was a big hubbub
when the Republicans forced their way in
the thing is this subpoena was not
classified the subpoena that called him
to her to testify so the Republicans
actually saw a little bit of daylight
here and they went in what is this all
about
is this about Ukraine no is this about
Joe Biden
not really I don't think the Democrats
are even that eager to nominate your
button this is about the 2020 election
because the Democrats do not believe
that they can beat Trump at the ballot
box they think that if they cannot
impeach Donald Trump that very likely he
will be re-elected I'm this is not just
psychobabble this is not just me trying
to read the minds of Democrats this is
actually from the mouths of loudmouth
Democrats themselves including
representative Al Green back in May
you've been calling for starting
articles of impeachment since 2017 but a
new Quinnipiac poll taken after the
release of the redacted Mulder report
found that 66% say Congress should not
start impeachment proceedings and
there's a sharp partisan divide as we
all know with only 4% of Republicans
favoring impeachment congressmen are you
concerned that impeachment talk may
actually help the president's reelection
I'm concerned that if we don't impeach
this president he will get reelected
pretty clear and I think he's probably
right Al Green he says outrageous and
ridiculous things in the house but he's
been around a while oh this guy knows a
thing or two about politics and I think
he's probably right if the Democrats
thought that they could beat President
Trump at the ballot box
they would not be trying to impeach him
I mean they have literally been trying
to impeach him since before he took
office Elizabeth Warren dick durbin
number of other leading Senate Democrats
tried to set the stage legislatively
before he took office to impeach him
House Democrats were were sending
letters to the government services
administration setting the stage for
impeachment before Trump took office
then Al Green tried to impeach him a
year ago two years ago they've just been
trying to do this because they're
they're initiating an impeachment in
search of a crime but what they believe
what the left believes is they are
losing their control on the culture
they're losing their control you were
supposed to win in 2016 they didn't and
so they've got to overturn that election
by any means necessary and at least some
guys like Al Green a very radical
but they're willing to say what they
mean so if if we are now at the point in
this country where the legislature run
by a different party is willing to
overturn the results of a presidential
election what does that mean for the
future of our country
some say we're headed for a civil war
actually the majority of Americans say
we're headed toward a civil war I think
there's another explanation before I get
to that speaking of security we have got
to thank our friends over at ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you already know about their smart video
doorbells how because I tell you about
them all the time in those smart video
doorbells protect millions of people
everywhere they help you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world if
there is a package delivery or a
surprise visitor you will know on your
ring so you can either be in the bedroom
or you can be at the office or you can
be on a beach somewhere it could be a
guy trying to break in and rob your
house you can talk to him two-way audio
and video it can be your mother-in-law
showing up unannounced
you probably don't talk to her you
probably just play dead you keep all the
lights off and you're just wait for her
to go away hopefully she doesn't find
out that you're there that is thanks to
HD video two-way audio and uploads to
the cloud so if the robber steals your
ring itself you will still have the
video it's a it's a really amazing
device I've given it out to my friends
as a housewarming gift
my producer Jonathan hey Jay hey he had
it in his house three in the morning
these drug-addled weirdos showed up he
was able to talk to them from his bed
and they just kind of ran away because
they knew he was home I gave it to
another friend of mine when they moved
into their new house and they heard this
creepy thing in the night they thought
maybe this isn't such a great
neighborhood who's around our house they
found out it was a possum now they
actually liked the possum and they can
see it on the little ring camera it's
just a tremendous piece of technology
and it really makes you feel safe gives
you peace of mind it's replacing the
neighborhood watch everywhere it's being
installed it's so easy and right now my
listeners get a special offer on a ring
starter kit right now with the video
doorbell and the motion activated
floodlight camera the starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home go to
ring comm slash Knowles cannon wles that
is ring dot-com
NOLs Kanna wles are we headed toward a
civil war that is what the majority of
Americans say not just a majority 2/3 of
Americans voters were asked on a zero to
100 scale to rate the level of political
divide in this country the value offered
for 100 was edge of a civil war the mean
response the average response was sixty
seven point two three that score was
similar to a 70 point seven seven score
from the April poll so you've got the
majority of Americans say we're headed
toward civil war and what they would say
is the likelihood of that is 67 percent
I don't think that we're headed toward a
civil war I think our future is even
bleaker than that I think we are headed
toward becoming Great Britain I know I I
don't I know I don't want this extreme
rhetoric like I've got to threaten my
countrymen and say we're about to become
a bunch of dirty rotten limeys but we
are we are headed toward becoming Great
Britain when people saw that scene
yesterday at the capital of Matt gates
and the Republicans storming into the
room when you actually watch the video
it's kind of restrained they couldn't
walk in I think they ordered pizza at
one point then they walked out and the
deposition went on the British
Parliament is far wilder than that if
you've ever watched Prime Minister's
Questions or any video of the the
British Parliament things get crazy
here's just take a listen this is just a
little glimpse of the British Parliament
at the time after he became prime
minister under the coalition at the time
when he was dividing the nation between
strivers and scrounges I asked him a
very important question about the
windfall he received when he wrote off
the mortgage of the premises in Notting
Hill and I said to him he didn't write
up the mortgage of the one the taxpayers
were helping to
paid for at Oxford I didn't receive a
proper answer then maybe dodgy Dave will
answer it now
and by the way
[Applause]
order order order order order that's not
like that was just members of a crowd
that was members of parliament and
they're all yelling oh and it's the end
that guy he sounds like he's trump dodgy
Dave crooked Hillary sleepy Joe so I
think we're headed in this direction and
that's a terrible thing that's a
terrible idea because we don't really
have the the history the roots the
tradition and the kind of cultural
similarity that the Brits do to pull
that off you know at least the Brits in
the one minute they can be screaming and
yelling and angry and Oh dah Oh Oh duh
and then the next minute they can be
making jokes about that which which they
often do Americans are a little more
earnest than those Brits and we're more
diverse and we're much more bound up by
our Constitution and by our shared
experience here than we are with just
the the incredible length of history
that the British people have so I think
probably it's I guess it's better than
civil war if we become Great Britain but
there is a fear here too we did become
very disorderly before the Civil War as
well I guess it can go one of two ways
we can either become the yelling
Parliament say ah dah order or we can
start shooting each other in fields in
Gettysburg hopefully it's the former
let's not forget right before the Civil
War there was a lot of strife in the
legislature there was the caning of
Charles Sumner where representative
Preston Brooks the Democrat from South
Carolina used his his walking cane to
attack Senator Charles Sumner who was an
abolitionist Republican and he nearly
killed Sumner it's not like he just
whacked him once on the back he nearly
killed the guy so are we heading toward
that Civil War
I'm skeptical you know the the civil war
involved a very serious moral question
are we debating moral questions right
now what what is the moral question
we're debating are we debating the phone
call to Ukraine is that a serious moral
question possibly withholding US aid to
Ukraine unless they investigate their
relations to the Obama administration
that's not a serious moral question so
directly we are not we are not debating
that there are however serious moral
questions boil
below the surface abortion we kill a
million babies a year and we've been
debating in for 50 years it's boiling
below the surface the nature of sex and
gender what that means for child abuse
if we're going to pump little kids full
of hormones and block them from going
through puberty so those those big
questions are there we're just not
talking about them directly we don't we
don't have either the moral clarity of
the abolitionists we don't we don't have
the local attachments of the
secessionists we don't have a serious
debate so I don't know that we're headed
towards civil war I think we're gonna
become Great Britain that's a very bad
thing because impeachment will run
roughshod over the executive branch and
and what it will do is create more or
less congressional supremacy just like
you have parliamentary supremacy in
Britain this that's is not good our
framers of our Constitution our founders
considered that they said should we just
make Congress them the main branch of
government and ultimately they said no
and they wrote about this in Federalist
65 Alexander Hamilton wrote this and he
dealt with the question of impeachment
if you give the Congress too much power
in impeachment then the executive the
president will just sort of be a puppet
to serve at the will and the pleasure of
the Congress so what Hamilton wrote and
fed 65 is quote a well constituted court
for the trial of impeachments is an
object not more to be desired than
difficult to be obtained in a government
wholly elective the subjects of its
jurisdiction are those offenses which
proceeded from the misconduct of public
men or in other words from the abuse or
violation of some public trust they are
of a nature which may with peculiar
propriety be denominated political as
they relate chiefly to injuries done
immediately to the society itself in
other words you can't you're not going
to impeach a president because he
jaywalked 20 years ago you're not going
to impeach a president because he has
unpaid parking tickets you're gonna
meetcha president for the acts that he
does that violate the public trust that
are political except where are you gonna
get a court to try these impeachments
because you you want a well constituted
court that isn't just going to use
impeachment as a as a power grab and
that is very difficult to find so
Hamilton goes on the prosecution of
these injuries for that this reason will
seldom fail to agitate the passions of
the whole community and to divide it
into parties more or less friendly or
inimical inimical to the accused in many
cases it will connect itself with the
pre-existing factions and will enlist
all their animosities partialities
influence and interest on one side or on
the other and in such cases there will
always be the greatest danger that the
decision will be regulated more by the
comparative strength of the parties than
by the real demonstrations of innocence
or guilt
it is like Alexander Hamilton is looking
into a crystal ball and seeing atom
shifts smug little face looking right
back at him and he says this is a bad
idea we don't want this to happen so
they ultimately decide is going to be
tried in the house is gonna be tried in
the Supreme Court is it and they
ultimately decide on the Senate not
because they think the Senate is some
great body they just think it's the
least bad body of all of them to try it
so Hamilton goes on he says quote where
else than in the Senate could have been
found a tribunal sufficiently dignified
or sufficiently independent what other
body would be likely to feel confidence
enough in its own situation to preserve
inaud & uninfluenced the necessary
immorality between an individual accused
and the representatives of the people
his accusers so Hamilton and the
founders and framers feared this they
did not want a sort of parliamentary
supremacy the supremacy of the House of
Representatives over the executive there
they're putting this in impeachment
let's not forget impeachment was not
invoked very often we did at Andrew
Johnson in the 1860s then we didn't do
it again until Richard Nixon in the
1970s then we did it 20 years later to
Bill Clinton then looks like we're gonna
do that 20 years later to Donald Trump
the speeding up of that means that you
are getting the Congress to more or less
treat the president like a prime
minister just as someone who is serving
when he wants to serve them and actually
on that point it's it's important to
note that Hillary Clinton might run for
a third time this seems like it it's
only if
a 20/20 election but it actually affects
the direction of our whole government
because what you're beginning to see is
permanent leaders of their parties who
come into office and out of office and
then go back into office again they're
nominated then they lose then they're
nominated again and they just have a
sort of semi-permanent control over
their party here's Hillary's one of her
top advisors Phillipe Ryan's going on
Tucker Carlson's show and and more or
less saying she's seriously considering
running for president man who was served
for decades as one of her closest aides
Philippe rains sleeps great to see the
night view to Tucker so I'm assuming
what I just said and what we're hearing
is true that if she thought she was the
best position to beat Donald Trump she'd
get the race she's not I would take
issue with the Macedonia part but other
than that I you know she ran for
president because she thought she would
be the best president if she still
thought that now if she thought she had
the best odds of beating Donald Trump I
think she would think about it long at
heart
I know she's not she doesn't foreclose
the possibility she has nothing so
really the question and that doesn't
surprise anybody who's followed the
clean house right well look this is a
huge if but if she had to jump in for
whatever reason and the party has moved
someplace that she hasn't then she won't
get the votes that's the point of the
primary there are I guess still 19
people there are a few that are in
double digits if she would have run and
people think that she's - left - right -
Center would ever want to call it that's
the beauty of it they get to vote
against whoever they want I don't know
she's not running because she has any
anxiety about the drag field she really
likes a lot of the people running she
knows the well she thought about some of
them for her vice presidency but there
might be a reason that she'd be the best
person not only to beat Donald Trump but
to govern after Donald Trump which is a
part we don't talk about much and look
you could make fun of her all you want
but 65 million people voted for her and
that's did you catch that little slip
from Philippe Rhines so the whole
interview is hypothetical yes she could
run maybe she'd run who knows then he
says look she's not running because she
has worries about other people in the
field
she's warm what did I say he referred to
her as though she is already running
anybody who's ever followed the Clintons
knows the Clintons do not go away
in the event of a nuclear holocaust
these two survivors will be the
cockroaches and the Clintons all right
they just survived political scandals
she is behaving as though she's running
she's on this book tour now which is
more or less putting around the campaign
trail she's talking like she's running
she's sniping at other candidates like
she's running and she's sending her
advisor on one of the biggest new shows
on cable to tell people in the present
tense that she is running and say the
reason she's running is not that she
doesn't like these other candidates it's
that oh whoops ooh did I say that this
is probably the clearest sign yet that
we're becoming Great Britain before we
get to that we have to thank our friends
over at we the people holsters it is
very very important to have a good
reliable holster for your firearm you go
you invest money into your firearm the
firearm is designed to keep you and your
family safe you clean it you take it to
the range you're all ready to go and
then you buy some cheap holster that's
not gonna fit your firearm that well
that doesn't make any sense make sure
that you get the best you can get the
best from with the people holsters
starting at just 37 bucks to get
custom-made holsters right here in
America their designs are made in-house
they even have their own 3d design team
which measures every micro millimeter of
their guns to ensure the perfect fit
their unique and intuitive design allows
for you to easily adjust both the can't
and ride of your holster so that it will
fit comfortably and securely at all
times these are really really high
quality they fit your gun perfectly just
like a glove and they have really great
designs I also love that they're
designed and made here in America that
just adds to the whole ethos of the
thing but most importantly I like the
functionality because they fit your guns
so so well go to We the People holsters
dot-com slash Knowles came to wles get
yours today
every holster ships free and it comes
with a lifetime guarantee
enter the code Knowles kano wles receive
an additional $10 off your orders now
you're looking at what 27 bucks to get a
real top-of-the-line
holster it's an incredible deal defend
the Constitution and support a great
American business satisfaction
guaranteed we the people holsters
dot-com
/ Knowles Cana wles offer code Knowles
Cana wles so you got filly prawns going
on TV saying Hilary's running you've got
a New York Times op-ed also raising the
prospect of Hillary 3.0 and that came
out that certainly came out with the
push of the Clinton team nothing happens
by accident in the New York Times and
nothing about the Clintons happens by
accident either this is a parliamentary
process you know remember a Winston
Churchill Winston Churchill was the
prime minister 1942-1945
and he gets kicked out of power when he
returns as the Prime Minister 1951 to
1955 this is what happens in in
parliamentary government's you have long
term leaders of parties and when the
party comes into power and the leader of
that party generally becomes the prime
minister that's the direction we're
headed in we shouldn't do that this
happens when people mistakenly believe
they want to become more democratic so
they say yeah if we want to be more
democratic than the institution elected
by the people should dominate the whole
federal government the founders
considered that they thought it was a
very bad idea we have the most
brilliantly constituted Republic in the
history of the world we have an
incredible and delicate balance of
powers and a separation of powers that
has allowed our country to thrive a
separation of powers between the three
branches of government the legislature
and the judiciary and the executive this
corresponds just to show you how
brilliant our founders were this
corresponds to the tripartite soul this
corresponds to the three aspects of our
soul the law Gauss the ethos and the
pathos so the the sort of emotional part
the part that responds to feeling the
pathos the that that would be
represented in the legislature the sort
of raw pure unadulterated logical part
is represented in the judiciary the
logos and then the ethos the spirited
part of the government and of our own
persons is representative in in that
executive who is the spirited part of
the country all three now do they do
they work perfectly of course not
because it's
human institution but they worked very
very well we then also separate powers
from the federal government to the state
level to the local level this is a
brilliant structure that we have been
consistent I don't say we that the left
has been consistently trying to destroy
for over a hundred years you begin that
with the direct election of senators so
you remove so much of the state power
the states basically have no say in the
federal government anymore now there are
calls to abolish the Electoral College
now they're going to be calls to abolish
the the significance of presidential
elections to abolish the legal basis for
impeachment proceedings and basically
just let the House of Representatives do
whatever they want to do even if it sort
of works in the UK that doesn't mean
it's going to work here and it doesn't
really work that well in the UK but at
least the UK is such a unified people
and they have such a long history and
they're so peculiar that it they don't
even really need a constitution in the
UK because because of the weight of
history in the United States we do we're
a very very young country we take in
more immigrants than anybody in history
of the world every year and we try to
assimilate them into American culture
though the left increasingly doesn't
want us to do that we have very little
that holds us together
we need to preserve this delicate
structure that has served us well for so
long the left doesn't want that to
happen you know I've got some very very
bad news from the campaign trail
this is is really I hope it doesn't
happen but I've got to let you know who
Leon Castro may drop out of the 2020
race and when who Leon Castro the man
who made presidential history by
endorsing abortion rights for men during
during a presidential debate when he
drops out I'm pretty much done with this
with this presidential election you know
what he's doing is he's saying if we
don't raise $800,000 in the next 10 days
my campaign is over now what he's trying
to copy is cory booker's strategy of
saying if we don't raise one point seven
million dollars in nine days the
campaign will be over and he did it he
made a lot of money so Castro is
actually given his voters a pretty good
deal Castro is also polling at 0.6% so I
don't think his campaign is long for
this world I'm gonna be very sad when it
goes away it's one of the most
Kilis and frivolous campaigns I've ever
seen so we wish him well I don't know
maybe I'll donate just to keep him on
that debate stage we have got to get to
one amazing little clip from AOC trying
to grill Mark Zuckerberg doing her best
charlie day impression from Always Sunny
and some actually pretty good news out
of Syria then we got the mailbag but
first I got to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube head over to daily wire.com
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership and by the way you get access
to some of the greatest fashion in the
entire world I am telling you right now
today as we face down cancel culture as
we face down the left censorship and
nonsense you can head over whether
you're a subscriber or not you can head
over to the daily wire store at Amazon
and you can get this sweet looking
fashionable cool and hip cancel cancel
culture t-shirt I will be your model
about that how great does that look I
should go on a catwalk or something head
on over to Daley wire.com head on over
that Amazon store we will be right back
with the mailbag
so we've got some good news out of Syria
some relatively good news out of Syria I
mention this because all we're talking
about her the political fights and the
battles and the campaigns and the
impeachment and the Hillary's gonna run
again you remember you remember two
weeks ago President Trump announced the
decision to redeploy troops out of
northern Syria people pretended like
this was the worst moment in American
history they all pretended like they
knew anything about Syria they all
pretended they could find Syriana man
they pretended they knew who the Syrian
free army was and the the YPG group of
Kurds and the PKK group of Kurds and
they then felt a little awkward because
they didn't realize that one group of
Kurds is officially designated a
terrorist organization in the United
States and then they pretended to know
the intersections of Iran and Russia and
Turkey and all then they just didn't
know anything we were told the sky was
gonna fall we were told the Kurds were
gonna be completely massacred wiped off
the face of the earth Turkey was going
to keep just marching all the way into
Syria and it didn't happen it didn't
happen what President Trump did was then
instant instituted some sanctions
against Turkey said I'll destroy your
economy if you don't stop invading Syria
and if you wipe out the Kurds so Turkey
stopped there was a ceasefire that was
initiated people said it wouldn't last
it looks like it's last and president
Trump is declaring victory well thank
you very much my fellow Americans I
greet you this morning from the White
House to announce a major breakthrough
toward achieving a better future for
Syria and for the Middle East it's been
a long time over the last five days you
have seen that a ceasefire that we
established along Syria's border has
held and it's held very well beyond most
expectations early this morning the
government of Turkey informed my
administration that they would be
stopping combat and their offensive in
Syria and making the ceasefire permanent
and it will indeed be permanent however
you would also define the word permanent
in that part of the world as
what questionable we all understand that
but I do believe it will be permanent
I've therefore instructed the Secretary
of the Treasury to lift all sanctions
imposed okay he goes on there's a lot
more to it obviously but what happens at
the end of this Syria decision American
troops are still in the country though
they've redeployed out of that area no
Americans have been killed and the fear
was that an American might be killed
even as a tripwire might be killed like
Americans were killed in the Beirut
bombings in 1983 Turkey has stopped
going in Bashar Assad is basically
safely ensconced in power and now Turkey
and Syria and Iran and Russia are trying
to figure out what to do with that
territory in Syria what end did you want
to this what enemies were also being
told this is terrible Russia wins Iran
did they win I don't know is it a win to
occupy Syria doesn't seem like a win
that seems like a big loss for American
foreign policy what's what's the
objective here regardless of your answer
to that question if you have an answer
which most people will not this worked
out pretty well right this is a no one's
gonna know that because no one's gonna
follow the story anymore all they're
gonna follow is the one week or two
weeks of total hysteria from the
mainstream media which has now moved on
and starts talking about how Matt Gaetz
is a pending precedent in the House of
Representatives but this worked out fine
and for all of the hand wringing about
Syria everything worked out relatively
pretty well what this tells us is on
these actual policy matters just take a
deep breath just wait because if you
have a little ounce of humility you will
realize that perhaps you don't know
everything about Syrian foreign policy
and maybe we aren't headed toward civil
war maybe we aren't headed toward
Armageddon maybe the country isn't
unraveling maybe there is some sort of
stability here before we get to the
mailbag I just have to I have to show
you this clip take a listen to
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes grilling Mark
Zuckerberg so you have Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes by her own admission not
the expert let's put it that way okay
not not the brightest bulb in the pack
not the sharpest tool in the shed
grilling Mark Zuckerberg one of the most
intelligent people on earth it goes
pretty much as well as you would expect
with a complete lack of fact-checking on
political advertisements
well congresswoman I think lying is bad
and I think if you were to run an ad
that had a lie that would be bad that's
different from it being from from or in
our position the right thing to do to
prevent your constituents or people in
an election from seeing that you had
lied so we can so you won't take down
lies or you will take down lies so I
think it's just a pretty simple
yes-or-no congresswoman I'm not talking
out spin I'm talking about actual yes in
a democracy I believe that people should
be able to see for themselves what
politicians that they may or may not
vote for you won't take so you won't -
you may flag that it's wrong but you
won't take it down
congresswoman it's a it depends on the
context that it shows up organic post
one question one more question she
obviously doesn't know very much of what
she's talking about you could you could
make that statement after almost
anything that IOC says what Mark
Zuckerberg could have responded though
and he was trying to keep his composure
and seem like he's a being very
respectful that's why he keeps referring
to his congresswoman is she's asking him
to censor his her political opponents
she's saying you're not gonna take down
things that I deem lies in politics in
politics each side is always calling the
other side liars so let's say to use a
similar example that she gives let's say
that a politician runs an ad and says
AOC is gonna raise your taxes and aoc
says I'm not gonna raise your taxes I'm
only gonna raise taxes for certain
people and I'll actually balance it out
and write this kind of typical fights
you hear this in almost every single
election and aoc says I demand you take
down that post that says I'm gonna raise
your taxes which is more or less what
she's asking for what if it were a TV
commercial
AOC is going to raise your taxes
I'm a o C's opponent I approve this
message are you gonna demand that cable
providers take down that message because
AOC doesn't like it what if it's a pom
card what if it's a little pamphlet
that's been sent in the mail are you
gonna demand that the post office
censors that pom card censors that
campaign information no of course not
but with Facebook they see an opening
his Facebook has so much power and it's
so new that they see an opening for the
left to just grab hold of this entire
institution and Zuckerberg acquitted
himself pretty well and he refused to
kowtow to her AOC is also upset the Mark
Zuckerberg has been having dinner with
conservatives and she goes after him in
your ongoing dinner parties with
far-right figures some of who advanced
the conspiracy theory that white
supremacy is a hoax did you discuss
so-called social media bias against
conservatives and do you believe there
is a bias congresswoman remember
everything that was in the Senate in the
course all right I'll move on can you
explain why you've named the Daily
Caller
a publication white well documented with
ties to white supremacist as an official
fact checker for facebook congresswoman
sure we actually don't appoint the
independent fact checkers they go
through an independent organization
called the independent fact-checking
network that has a rigorous standard for
who they allow to to serve as a fact
checker so you would say that white
supremacist tide publications meet a
rigorous standard for fact-checking
Thank You congresswoman I would say that
we're not the one assessing that that
standard the international fact-checking
network is the one who is setting that
standard so this is why you can't let
AOC control Facebook is because she says
look I'm not trying to censor people who
put spin I'm just trying to censor you
know liars and then in the very next
sentence she refers to the Daily Caller
which is a completely mainstream
conservative outlet as a white
supremacist outlet just there's no basis
for that whatsoever so she's a liar does
she get does she get censored on
Facebook probably not but what she would
do is cut any any way
organization to the right of Hillary
Clinton probably any organization to the
right of Bernie Sanders she would sense
her from Facebook and it's just that
it's the arrogance it's that smug
unbelievable arrogance she says you've
been having dinner with these far-right
figures listen to this business just
fruit salad of words some far-right
figures some of whom believe the
conspiracy theory that white supremacy
is a hoax so she's saying she's saying
the premise is our government is white
supremacists that we're pretty much
living in the antebellum South were
living with slaves black slaves on the
basis of their skin color and we're
living in this you know kind of fever
dream of leftists and if you don't
believe that if you don't think we're
living in the pre Civil War South then
you're a conspiracy theorist that's what
a OC is saying watching her try to grill
Mark Zuckerberg did remind me that I
think this was actually a reenactment
with Charlie Day playing a OC on Always
Sunny in Philadelphia I know a lot about
the lawn various other lawyer rings
where did you go to law school again
well I could ask you that very same I
went to Harvard
[Music]
all right now let's say you want to go
toe-to-toe on bird law and see who comes
out to victory no it was my lawyer rings
you know and all my various no not at
all all right let's get to the mailbag
now that we've seen that reenactment of
AFC from Evan hey Michael being that you
have the best hair at the Daily wire
partially due to keeps I was wondering
what kind of hair products do you use I
woke up like this also just a little bit
of spray to kind of hold it in place
from Claire my friend is Christian and
will marry an atheist this year her
fiancee is a wonderful man and I'm
thrilled she's happy however since I am
a Christian and will be standing next to
her for her wedding I feel like I have a
responsibility to say something
interested to know your thoughts Thanks
well how likely is he to come on over
and see the light is part of the
question another question is how are
they gonna raise the kids
they're gonna raise the kids atheists
it's probably not gonna work if they're
gonna raise the kids Christian and the
husband will kind of go along with it
okay that's a good start the other
question is about the wedding itself you
know the Catholic Church has still
actually has a fairly rigorous standard
for this they've kind of loosened up
rules a little bit after the
loosey-goosey mid 20th century but you
know in the Catholic Church marriage is
a sacrament it's not just like something
you can do on the beach in your
flip-flops so you've really there are a
lot of kind of aspects to it because it
is a real sacrament and so there's a
long period of talking to priests and
doing pre marriage training which is
called pre Cana and you're really
sussing out a lot of these questions so
the question is your Christian your
friend is a Christian what does it even
mean to be standing next door is this
going to be in a church now if the
fiancee is agreeing to be married in a
church with a priest or a pastor and
there's a kind of liturgy to it and
they're saying this is a sacrament
before God then I don't know I guess
he's probably heading down the right
path and you should encourage him along
the way if not if this is a kind of
loosey-goosey thing and some friend is
officiating it in the backyard then you
have to ask what is the marriage in the
first place I think a lot of people get
married these days and they just don't
really agree to what marriages there was
some Hollywood degenerate I forget which
one because it's could describe all of
them who said he got married and shortly
after he got married he told his wife
look we can't do this monogamy thing all
right I need to go sleep with other
women we got to get non-traditional here
and this poor woman agreed to go along
with it what else is she going to do but
obviously that's not that's not a
marriage in any way that we imagine a
marriage to be and and maybe they didn't
sign up for a normal marriage you know I
mean are you really are you really
believing what you say and in the vows
you're really gonna cherish this person
faithfully and whose sickness and in
health and good times and in bad times
until the end of your lives until death
do you part or is this one of these kind
of modern hippy things I'm like we're
gonna write our own vows you know and
it's like hey I really loved when Johnny
washes the dishes and I promised always
you know like leave the remote on the
coffee table ha ha
like okay if it's that then you're not
taking marriage all that seriously in
the first place so you you know as
always in this era words are being
really distorted out of their original
meaning so you got to make sure going in
I'm not saying the guy needs to convert
and be all ready to go and the most
Christian guy in the world even before
the wedding but I'm saying your friend
and her fiance need to know what they're
signing up for and if they're not on the
same page it's much better to catch that
earlier rather than later from Ben after
his third term in office who's face on
Mount Rushmore will be replace with
Donald Trump it's prudent we begin now
to discuss this as this will be a point
of contention in few years sincerely ben
thomas jefferson no question next
question john joe rogan recently had
richard dawkins on his podcast they were
discussing christianity specifically
with regard to miracles surrounding
jesus mr. Dawkins promoted the idea that
other than the resurrection
sophisticated theologians believe that
all other miracles are either metaphors
didn't really happen are not important
or symbolic okay so as a sophisticated
theologian do you believe only in the
resurrection and dismiss all the other
miracles is something else or do you
think that if Jesus is truly God then
turning water to wine isn't that big of
a deal as usual Richard Dawkins has no
idea what he's talking about you'll
notice he doesn't name the sophisticated
theologians because he can't and if he
can name any sort of theologian at all
who believes that I promise you they're
not sophisticated you know it was a
pretty sophisticated theologian Thomas
Aquinas st. Thomas Aquinas you know it
was another pretty sophisticated
theologian Saint Agustin would be one
the church fathers st. jerome i guess i
could go on and on they all believed in
the miracles and richard dawkins is not
a sophisticated theologian he's not a
theologian at all so no i'm not a
theologian a theologian or theologian
myself but i do read them and certainly
certainly the miracles are very
important they are essential to
christianity also ask yourself this if
jesus christ is the son of God the
divine logic of
universe born of the father before all
ages God from God light from light true
God from True God begotten not made
consubstantial with the father incarnate
in aver incarnate of of the Holy Spirit
conceived in a virgin born into this
world dies on the cross to redeem man
redeem man from his sin then three days
later rises from the dead you you can go
along with all of that but you can't
believe that he turns water into wine
that's it that's too much for you you
believe the whole other thing but like
you can't possibly turn water into wine
that's not a very sophisticated
theological idea okay that's our show
I'm Michael noses the Michael Nolt show
I'm gonna be in Nashville this weekend
debating the guy who called me skinny
boy Chris Hahn we're gonna be at
politican in Nashville so if you're in
Nashville head on over there check it
out at politican and if not I'm sure
we're gonna be streaming it so I will
see you there have a good weekend I'll
see on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by my core amina hair and
makeup is by joshua alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you